good morning hank it's tuesday it's
question tuesday the day that i answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it favorite creature
of the land
sea and sky humans humans who are
currently swimming
and owls did you see that a beautifully
foolish endeavor is a new york times
best seller
i did hank congratulations what are your
thoughts on finding silver linings in
times of global distress
i think we need silver linings in hard
times and that joyful experiences should
still be joyful and that good news
should be sought and welcomed and
celebrated what i'm suspicious of is
attempts to make silver linings out of
suffering itself
especially other people's suffering that
reminds me of this great clint hill
smith poem that i'll link to below it's
called when people say we have made it
through worse before and it begins all i
hear
is the wind slapping against the
gravestones of those who did not make it
when was the last time you hugged
someone not in your immediate family
march 11th and it was hank what's your
morning routine and would you recommend
it
wake up put on clothes brush my teeth
doom scroll through covet news for 45
minutes
i wouldn't recommend it which lyric in
all star is your favorite i don't know
why people keep asking me about this 19
year old pop song it's very weird but
anyway my favorite lyric in it is
probably the year start coming and they
don't stop coming i could listen to that
for like 10 hours
by which i mean i really could listen to
that for 10 hours
what are owls plotting when they stare
at us with those big eyes
uh i for one will welcome our new owl
overlords i will be so excited when the
owls announced that they're just taking
over because they don't like the way
that we've handled all this
what's going on with the project in
sierra leone a lot for those who don't
know we're helping support partners in
health and the sierra leonean ministry
of health in a multi-year project to
strengthen the health care system with a
focus around maternal mortality you can
learn more
i'm bad at pointing but obviously
covid19 is a huge challenge to
healthcare systems around the world like
at coitu government hospital in sierra
leone which pih helped support the
emergency department had to close for a
time because some healthcare workers
contracted covid19 which meant that
others had to self-isolate
and there were no healthcare workers to
replace them but the emergency
department is back up and running and
seeing lots of patients and pih has been
deeply involved in contact tracing and
screening efforts around sierra leone
and cases overall are down 18
from their peak pah sierra leone has a
lot of expertise when it comes to
contact racing and that's been vital
not just in sierra leone but around the
world like partners in health is heading
up the contact tracing program for
massachusetts
also in really good news later this
month at coyote government hospital the
special baby care unit will open which
will be a
huge milestone in providing better care
for infants
so i think there's a lot of encouraging
news but it is also really really
difficult like i've heard that seeing
healthcare workers in ppe and smelling
chlorine can be really triggering for
people who have ptsd
after surviving the ebola crisis and so
any effective healthcare response has to
include mental health care and real
listening and
reassurance as dr martino said of the
approach to care during this crisis
kindness patience information empathy
empathy empathy in terms of our
community's response it's been
incredible in fact donations have
continued to go up every month even amid
everything so thank you you can learn
more at pih.org
hank and john how does it feel now that
you can find wallet island on google
maps
really lovely it would be a wonderful
quota to my book paper towns if a place
that only exists sometimes
became real because it was named on a
map how do you feel about schools
reopening
worried what's your most common
quarantine activity oh worrying there's
not even a close second
john how does it feel to know your
brother is tick-tock famous uh mostly
good but
a little worrying are you writing
another book i am how do i make friends
online
i recommend online nerdfighter
communities links in the doobly-doo are
you and hank ever going to use that
vacation time there was a poll about
over a year ago yes so last year
nerdfighteria voted to give us three
weeks of vacation per year i have not
used much of that vacation but i am
gonna take next week off because my
brain requires it i hope that's okay
hank congratulations
again on a beautifully foolish endeavor
hitting the new york times best seller
list i will see you on friday unless you
also need to take vacation which is fine